[Music]
kanye west's reportedly skipping the
Grammy Awards Sunday even though he is
nominated for eight Awards why because
back in October Konya vowed to boycott
the show if Frank Ocean didn't receive a
nomination for his blonde album but
Frank was reportedly ineligible for not
submitting the album in time but
Connie's beef with the Grammys isn't new
there's over a decade of complicated
history so let's talk about it the
Grammys have both snubbed and celebrated
Kanye over the years he's won 21 Awards
off of 57 nominations most of those
earlier on in his career but he has been
nominated every year since 2008 which is
the most of any hip-hop artist and the
sixth most of any male artist if you
really dive into it what I gathered from
your articles Kanye's correct isn't
really about him it's more on behalf of
the other artists
Kanye's first Grammys all the way back
in Gregory first me win first Grammy win
Best Rap Album for college dropout in
2005 along with Jesus walks for the best
rap song he later performed on stage in
2007 and 2009 which you might remember
is the same year he had his now-famous
Taylor Swift VMA mic grabbing the mic
crab which kind of resulted in a little
bit of fallout I would say he didn't
show up to another Grammys telecast for
five years and during that five years is
when he released My Beautiful Dark
Twisted Fantasy the best album there was
which did actually win Best Rap Album
into 2012 but was not nominated for
album of the year
same year actually got passed over was
Watch the Throne his collaboration with
jay-z that was a pretty infamous snub so
he reappeared in 2015 and that was the
year that he kind of joked about
crashing the stage with Beck but then we
found out he was actually completely
serious and actually thought that
Beyonce should have won that award last
year was 2016 and he wasn't there but he
did make a lot of headlines because that
was near the Taylor Swift got on stage
and slammed him for his lyrics in a song
famous
about a week after that was when Kanye
went on this Twitter rant about the
Grammys mentioning that the Recording
Academy is not culturally irrelevant the
awarding system is out of touch and that
too many politics are in play to
actually win the Grammy Award not just
being nominated so will Kanye's show up
at the Grammys on Sunday or not is he
gonna skip it all together
well we actually asked a producer Ken
Ehrlich and here's what he had to say
Kanye it's probably gonna be a question
of it'll it'll happen it will or won't
happen closer to the shelves he's
nominated for some really big awards and
there would be great to have him with us
of course
et will have any and all updates from a
carpet to the after-party so keep it
locked here on ET online for all your
Grammys news and thank you for breaking
down your article I'll check it out if
you have it thank you so much
[Music]
you